The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
so today our topic
is going to be depth
perception, which,
as I have mentioned
to you before,
is certainly one of the
most intriguing achievements
in vision.
Because the impressions
onto the retinal surface
essentially two dimensional.
And from that, somehow
the brain needs
to reconstruct the
third dimension.
And what is interesting
about this also,
that even in the most primitive
animals, this is a must.
And so annals with
tiny brains also
have mechanisms to be
able to calculate depth
from the information that
comes in through their eyes.
And to demonstrate
that, I have here
a frog, which has a tiny little
brain like that, has big eyes,
and this frog,
for its existence,
needs to know exactly
where things are in depth.
Because if he doesn't,
he would starve to death.
And so what a frog does
looks something like this,
very crudely.
He will stick out his
tongue, grab a flying insect
and consume it.
And because of this
incredible capability,
it is a well-adjusted,
healthy animal
in most parts of the world.
Now the big question
then comes up,
how do we carry out
these computations.
What kind of
mechanisms are involved
in being able to compute
where things are in space,
either in absolute sense
where it is from you
and in a relative sense
where one object is
relative to another one.
Now it turns out that this
became such a serious problem,
in the course of
evolution, that actually
several different
mechanisms have evolved
to make possible our ability
to see things in depth.
And so when one looks at this as
a list, as a fairly brief list,
we can make a distinction
between so called ocular motor
cues and visual cues.
The ocular motor cues are
accommodation and vergence.
So if various objects are
at a very distance from you,
your eyes converge or diverge.
And you your lens gets
thicker and thinner.
And that information can be
utilized in a rather crude way
to tell you about where things
are in that relative to you.
Now as far as visual
cues are concerned,
the very significant
one we are going
to talk about quite a
bit, is a binocular cue,
which is called stereopsis
as you all know.
And then we have a whole
bunch of monocular cues motion
parallax, shading,
interposition, size,
and perspective.
And so we will talk
about many of these
to give you a sense
of what it is like
and to give you a sense of what
various brain structures do
with this as a result
of extensive research
that had been done in this area.
So now, first of all, let's
talk about stereopsis.
And we talk about
stereopsis, we're
going to talk about
the basic facts of it,
and then we are going to
have some demonstrations.
First of all, the so
called stereoscope,
of whichever modern version
that has been handed out to you,
the stereoscope was invented
in the late 19th century.
And when that was done, the
initial approach to this
was to be able to present
to each eye separately
an image that was
taken by a camera that
has two lenses, which are apart
about as much as your two eyes
are apart.
And each of those
created a separate image
of what's out there.
And, of course, each eye gets
a very slightly different
perspective of what's there.
And then when you
present these two images
that you had collected
separately to each eye,
you get a very strong
sense of real depth,
as you will see
in just a minute.
Now another way to do it,
which nowadays is easier
because you can
barely ever find even
one of these two-lens
cameras, even in stores that
sell ancient materials,
antique stores.
So sometimes what
you do instead,
if you only want to take a
picture of a static image,
that you can take a
camera, put in a track,
and have it take two
pictures in succession.
And then you can
do the same thing
as you do with a serial camera.
You can present one to each eye.
OK, so, what we are
going to do now,
we are going to have
a series of demos.
And so we have a handout
for each of you, the paper.
And that you can
keep and take home.
But the stereoscope that
I have for each of you,
that you're going to
have to leave behind,
because I need to use
that in other classes.
So what I want you
to do then, there
are two pictures
on the first page
that you put the stereoscope
down onto the page
so that the vertical
line cuts it in half
so that one goes into each eye.
And then you put your
head right down to it
to look into it, all right?
And if you do that, if you
have it properly sectioned,
you're going to have a sense
that that image is actually
three dimensional.
It's an ancient, ancient
old picture on purpose.
But you should still be
able to see it in depth.
So that's the initial thing.
This became quite a parlor
game and for that case,
for many, many decades,
whenever you went to a party,
they would hand out to you a
stereoscope, a handheld one,
and they would show you
all kinds of images.
And you can even
do this today when
you get on the internet
to find such displays.
Now, then a very important
discovery was made.
I shouldn't say
discovery, really,
I should say an invention was
made by Bela Julesz who came up
with a so-called
random dot stereograms.
By the way, don't look at the
bottom one, that just tells you
what it's going to look like.
There's nothing to look at
the bottom, the bottom set.
Now if you look
in the middle set,
that looks like a
random dot stereogram.
And the idea here was that
the only cue that you provide
is stereo cue, nothing else.
It's pure.
And so what can
be done here, you
can take a section here,
or the same on each side,
and simply move a few pixels,
those images as a unit, over.
And when you do that, they're
going to stick out in depth.
So now take you stereoscope
and look in the middle display,
and you look through it,
you should see something
sticking out in depth.
And the first question I'm going
to ask you is how many of you
can see something
stick out in depth?
What do you see?
You see
AUDIENCE: A square.
PROFESSOR: A little
square sticking out?
All right, so now, don't try
to look at the bottom one.
That simply tells you what the
procedure was in that center
section where you see
the square sticking out.
The pixels were moved a few
steps inward from both the left
and to the right creating
what is called a disparity.
And that's what the brain
then can calculate for depth.
So now to provide you
with the acid test,
go to the second page.
Now you look at the
second page, everybody
see the letter on top?
You don't even have to look
through the stereoscope,
obviously you see
the letter E, right?
That's because that
section is made darker.
But now if you do the same thing
at the bottom, the only cue
you have is the disparity cue.
And the question comes up,
what letter do you see there?
And let me just add, this can be
used as a quick, general test.
You can present
these two subjects,
and if it can present a whole
bunch of different letters,
and if they can see the letters,
that means they can see stereo.
If they cannot see the letters,
then it looks like they may not
see stereo.
Now let me add one
other fact here.
As you move these progressively
closer to each other like this,
you increase the disparity.
And that causes the image to
be seen at increasing depths.
Our sensitivity is
so great that when
you look at this on a
computer, a standard computer,
if you move those
images just one
pixel from the left
to the right, then
from right to the left,
you will see it in depth.
And even monkeys can see
as small step as one pixel.
So now how many
of you can tell me
what was the letter
at the bottom there?
AUDIENCE: H.
PROFESSOR: H, H, good.
Anybody not being able
to see the letter?
Everybody sees it.
Well, you guys are lucky.
Because there are a
significant number
of people in the world
who lack stereopsis,
something like 5% to
10% of the population
lacks stereopsis for
a variety of reasons.
We'll talk about that
a bit more later.
But one is sometimes
you're born,
and you're amblyopic in one eye.
Sometimes you are
strabismic, which
means that your two
eyes are not aligned,
which in commonplace
language is often
called as being cross
eyed or wall eyed.
Those types of
people very seldom
will have stereoscopic
depth perception,
even after it's
corrected, especially
if the correction is made by the
time you're 8 or 10 years old,
the correction won't help.
It has to be done
much, much earlier.
All right, so that then
is the very, very basics
of the stereo procedures.
And now another
procedure that had
been developed more
recently is one
which is called the
auto stereogram.
So then if you go to the next
page, and what you want to do
is you want to look at
this horizontally like that
with the T on top.
And then just look at it at
sort of, I don't know, maybe
about 20 inches from you,
normal reading length.
And what you want to do
is to look beyond it.
So stare beyond it.
And if you keep doing
that for a while,
you will suddenly see an image,
a three-dimensional image,
as this comes actually from
a book called The Magic Eye.
There are several
magic eye books
in which all kinds
of displays are
done using these
auto stereograms.
Does everybody see-- who
can see what's sticking out?
OK, what do you see?
AUDIENCE: Was it a shark?
PROFESSOR: You see a shark?
OK.
Now let me see if any
of you don't see it.
Keep staring at it.
Look beyond it.
Another thing that
helps, if you look at it,
bring it a little
closer to you so you
can look beyond it
easier, gradually
move it back and forth.
And if you're patient,
eventually you
may be able to do this.
The reason this is
difficult is because you
have to uncouple the
vergence in your two eyes.
You have to look
beyond it slightly.
And, in fact, that is
one of the reasons why
testing people for
stereopsis, an auto stereogram
is not a very good procedure.
Whereas virtually everybody
can use a stereoscope
without any trouble.
AUDIENCE: That's so cool.
PROFESSOR: Did you
get it finally?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's so cool.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, all
right so, if anybody
is really interested in
this auto stereograms
is I say go to the
store, the bookstore,
and get one of those
magic eye books.
They're just a lot of fun.
And you can just
leaf through it.
You don't even have to buy
the book, just look through it
at the store.
And you'll see one interesting,
clever image after the next.
All right, so that's
the stereoscope.
And now let me
explain to, I think
I've mentioned this briefly
before, the principles involved
behind being able to see
stereoscopic depth perception.
And what I've mentioned
to you before was
that if you have the
two eyes fixating
at a particular distance, if you
then draw a circle around that,
that's sometimes called
a Veith-Muller circle,
or the sometimes called a
horopter, then any target,
like this one here, will
hit equivalent points
on the retinal surface of
the left and right eyes.
However, if you
do the same thing,
and you put a target
either beyond or closer
than the Vieth-Muller
circle, then they're
going to hit nonequivalent
points on the retinal surface.
So then by nonequivalency, we
can do this and calculate this
as to where the
image falls relative
to the central fixation
spot in the foveola.
And so then, when these
nonequivalent points are hit,
somehow the brain can
measure this nonequivalence.
And that is then
converted into an estimate
of where things are in depth.
Now the idea behind
this was that
these nonequivalent
points, that you
have on the retinal surface,
can connect in the cortex
to single cells.
So they have a cell in the
cortex that is binocular,
by virtue of the
fact that inputs
from the left and right eyes.
But they don't necessarily have
to come from equivalent points.
They can come from
nonequivalent points.
And that may be then
the mechanism whereby
it can tell you the
degree of nonequivalence,
and, therefore, convert
that into depth.
And, therefore, there
could be single neurons
in the brain that are
selective to certain depths.
And so people began to do all
kinds of experiments with this.
And the way these
experiments were done
is you presented
images separately
to the left eyes and right eyes.
And you could then present them
to both eyes at the same time
and vary the amount of
disparity systematically
to see what kind
of tuning function
you would get in the cortex.
So this, some of the most
beautiful work of this
was done by a person
called John [? Porgio ?]
And I will tell you briefly
about some of his experiments.
So here we go with then.
We're going to look at
the neural responses,
neural responses in V1 as
initially done in the monkey.
So here's an example of a cell.
We have here different
degrees of disparity.
And we have the
neuron responding
each time they're
four repeated trials.
And you can see the action
potentials by these dark lines
here.
And what you do is you move
the stimuli back and forth
across the two eyes, the
way it's actually done,
you have a mirror.
And then you have two
in this experiment.
You have two monitors, one to
the left and one to the right.
And then you can set
it up almost exactly
the same as what you would
do with a stereoscope.
So this particular cell,
as you can readily see,
responds best when
there's zero disparity.
Now by contrast, here is a
cell that responds vigorously
at the far disparity and
not to the close one.
So then, when you do this, you
can study hundreds of cells
to see what kinds
of distributions
you have in the cortex for
different degrees of disparity,
cell activity.
Now again, this
hearkens back to what
I talked about with
respect to color vision
where the question came up,
if you want to see color,
how many receptors
would you need that peak
at different wavelengths, right?
And one idea was that maybe you
need as many photo receptors
as there are colors.
But in the end, it turned
out that we have only three
of them.
And on the basis of that, we
can recreate all the colors out
there.
Now the same thing
applies to stereopsis.
So when this was
done systematically,
here's an example of
the tuning functions.
This one here is the
same, very much the same,
as the first figure
I showed you.
And so we have a bunch
of different ones.
And if you then study, as
I've said hundreds of cells,
you can come up with a
distribution of this.
And what John
[? Porgio ?] came up with,
he thought that there
were four major classes.
And the relative amount
of activity of these four
major classes then is used
to compute all the very fine
differences in depth.
So there's a right on one.
This cell is right
on the fixation spot.
And then you have
near and far cells.
And you have some
in between cells.
Initially he thought
there were four classes.
Some people argue that
there may be as many as six.
But at any rate,
there's a limited number
on the basis of which
you can calculate
almost an unlimited
number of depths,
which is quite remarkable.
All right, so now, what
you can next turn to
is to ask the question to what
degree do various extrastriate
areas contribute to
stereoscopic depth perception.
And some people
thought that this
is a unique function
for area MT,
some people argue
that maybe it's
area V4, and so experiments were
done in which it was examined
to what degree stereoscopic
depth deception is altered when
you eliminate, say, area MT
or you eliminate area V4.
So that is what's been done.
And you can think
about it for a minute
and say, well,
what do you think?
What do you think would
happen in a monkey
once you no longer had area V4?
What you think would happen
if the monkey no longer had
area MT?
Well, the results were
actually quite surprising.
And they're shown here,
same experiment as before.
The Bela Julesz random
dot stereograms.
And then you're presenting
one of four locations
of however many
little area where,
like little square,
that's sticks out in depth
and you vary the amount
of depth that sticks out
by varying the
number of pixels you
moved the images
into this place.
And when that was
done systematically,
this is what was found.
It was found that neither
V4 lesion nor an MT lesion
cause a significant deficit.
The only deficit
that was significant
had to do with a
response latency.
And as I should have
mentioned earlier,
like when we talked
about the frog, one
of the very important things
about processing depth,
again, is to be able
to do it quickly.
So when you have that's frog
and the fly is flying along,
he has to be very
quick to compute it
so that he can catch it,
right, as you had seen.
So in this case,
what you see here,
that there is about a 20
millisecond difference
after V4 lesion, increase in
latency, and quite a bit more,
almost 40, 30, 40
after and MT lesion.
So that contributes to some
aspect of depth processing
in terms of being
able to do it quickly.
But neither the MT or V4
are unique in processing
stereopsis.
It looks like that
it is processed
in several different
areas in the brain
and inspire conjoint
computation that you
can arrive at the actual depth.
And it's by virtue of
that joint computation
that you can do
this very quickly.
So now you come to the
next important depth
cue, which is called
motion parallax.
This one is a capacity
that we had acquired
in the course of
evolution, which
is extremely potent
and powerful.
And it's based on a very
simple physical fact.
And the physical fact it that
either when you are in motion,
or something in
the environment is
in motion, the rate at
which these images travel
across the retinal surface is
heavily distance dependent.
And so let me demonstrate
this concretely for you.
Here we have an
eye that's fixed.
It's always looking
straight ahead.
And we have two rods
here, sorry, just one rod,
that we are going to move into
position gradually from here
to here, and then back up
as shown by the arrows here.
And we examine the
range over which
these near and far and
middle objects move
across the retinal surface
when you engage in this motion
and the eye is stable.
And you can see that
the far object moves
over a much shorter distance
than the near object.
This you can readily do it
yourself in an experiment.
You can stick out your thumb and
move your head back and forth.
And you see that your thumb will
move a lot more than the object
that you're looking at.
So now the same thing also
applies when you actually
are engaged in the eye
movements, which of course you
do all the time.
In this case, they eye is set up
so that it's fixated initially
on this object and
then tracks it to here
and then tracks it back.
And when you do that, you
get the same kind of effect,
namely that the distance over
which a far and a near object
move is quite different.
The near object moves over
much, much greater distance
than the far object, even
though the eyes are tracking.
So this, then, being
a basic physical fact,
was then used in the
course of evolution
to create mechanisms that are
sensitive to this differential
motion.
And, of course, because
of the rate of motion
also varies a little
bit, it became
possible to create mechanisms
to make that computation
to tell you where
things are in depth.
So here I'm going to show
you an actual demo of this
to make it clear to you.
In this case, again, we have
a bunch of random dots, much
like in the Bela Julesz
random dot stereograms
but just a single one.
And everybody agrees
there's no depth here.
Is there any depth?
Do you see any depth?
So now what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to set this image
into rocking motion.
And when I do this,
almost instantly, you're
going to see something in depth.
Are you ready?
So what you see here is
are three levels, right,
very clearly.
In milliseconds, in 20
milliseconds, you can see this.
And let me explain to
you why you see this.
If, OK, let me go
back and do it again.
If I keep this stable, you can
see that the dots move over
a great distance here,
a lesser distance
here, and practically
not at all here.
So there is a
differential motion.
And the greater the motion,
the closer the image
is in your analysis.
So that's called
motion parallax.
And then what you
can do actually,
you can play all kinds
of games, do experiments
in which you can present
this kind of image.
You can put this into each
of the eyes separately.
And you can present
this image alone
or you can present it paired
with disparity for stereopsis.
And you can do each separately
or you can do the two together.
So let's now first summarize
the essence of motion parallax.
To derive depth information
from motion parallax,
neurons are needed that
provide information
about velocity and
direction of motion
and perhaps also about
differential motion.
Secondly, the
majority of V1 cells
are direction and
velocity selective,
as we had discussed before,
and some appear also
to be selective for
differential motion, which
I did not mention before.
But, indeed, there are such
cells in the visual cortex.
Now, the third
important point is
that such cells that are
motion selective and direction
selective and selective
for differential motion
are very, very common area MT.
So those are some of the
very, very basic facts.
And now we can move on and ask
what kind of brain activation
occurs by stereopsis
and motion parallax
in normal and serial
blind subjects
using a recently
developed technique, which
is magnetic resonance imaging,
functional, functional
magnetic resonance imaging.
So how do you do
this kind of stuff?
Well, what you do here,
here's an example,
you have a very
large stereoscope
with a mirror at the end.
And you have a subject
who is lying down.
And this whole unit, except
not of course that part,
is put into the magnet.
And we have a magnet
down here at MIT.
Most of you probably
have seen that.
It's on the ground floor.
So you can do this, and then you
can present those images here.
And so the stereoscope
will present two images
and then you can vary this
by rocking him back and forth
either to present
only motion parallax
or present only stereopsis
and to present both.
And so now the question is, this
is a very primitive question
at this stage, where
in the brain are
these processes analyzed?
And so you can find out
what brain areas are
active by doing this repeatedly
collecting the fMRI data
and then printing
them out and looking
at them to see what happens.
So I'm going to show you
a couple examples of that.
Here is the basic
figure that the person
sees but done in such a
way that you can see it.
Of course, he doesn't
see anything like this.
He just sees different depths.
There are one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven different depths here.
And this rocks back and forth.
And then you can, as I
say, present this only
with differential motion
or you can present it only
with disparity or you
can present it with both.
And then finally, as a
control, what you do is
you can do the same thing.
But you don't have
any depth of any sort.
You just have a flat surface
rocking back and forth.
And then when you
do data analysis,
you actually subtract the last
one from the rest of the data
so that you're not looking at
the data for the activation
just by the spots but
for the activation that's
specific for stereopsis
or motion parallax.
So now if you do
this experiment,
here's an example
of a normal subject
and a stereobind subject.
And we have here a sagittal cut
adding up the images sideways.
And what you see here, this is
posterior cortex, of course.
Here in the normal subject,
when you present only motion
parallax, you only
analyze motion parallax.
But you have a huge amount of
activation in the visual areas.
And then if you
do the same thing
when you do a binocular
stereopsis only,
you also get a great
deal of activation,
in quite similar set of areas.
And then the big
crucial test comes up.
What happens if you present
the stereo under monocular
conditions when you
don't see stereo?
And if you do that, using this
same calculation procedures,
there is no brain
activation here.
And, therefore, what we see here
is due, indeed, to the analysis
that we do for stereopsis.
Now if you do the
same experiment
in a stereoblind subject who
has been tested, on tests
similar we had shown you,
when that person even
looks at it under
binocular conditions,
there is no brain
activation meaning
that this person doesn't have
any mechanisms in the brain
to analyze stereopsis.
Now the fortunate
thing is that we
have these several
different mechanisms
for depth perception.
And so people who are
stereoblind and have
no analysis for disparity, they
can still see depth reasonably
well.
And, indeed, they can get
driver's license and all
that, because we have all these
other mechanisms that include,
that we have talked
about, motion parallax.
So that then is one
way of looking at it.
Now the other way to look at it,
especially when I ask as well,
are the same brain areas
doing both or what.
And so what you
can do is instead
of doing a sagittal section,
you can take sections coronally
like bang, bang,
bang, bang like that
and see what that looks like.
And here's an example in which
I've isolated the stereo.
And here are a
bunch of sections.
And this shows the
activation for stereopsis.
You can see there are
all kinds of areas
that are being activated.
And then if you
do the same thing
and just look at
the parallax alone,
here we have the
activation for that.
And then lastly here,
we do both of them.
Now we can go back.
The way to look at
the question, how
are these two areas, these
two types of depth perception
analyses, differently
activating in the brain.
And so I'm going to
go back and forth
between stereo and parallax.
You can see, and that, you
can see the difference.
Now some regions,
which have a perfect
overlap, and
there's some regions
that are quite separate.
Notable here are
these areas here,
which are activated by
stereo but not by parallax.
So this then can provide
you with an initial idea
that there are some brain
areas in which both of these
are analyzed together.
And there's some
brain areas in which
are uniquely analyzed for either
stereopsis or motion parallax
alone.
Now this tells you where it
takes place in the brain.
But how it takes place requires
a totally different approach.
Namely, the most
comfortably to record
from individual neurons
in various areas
just like I had shown
you that nice work done
by John [? Porgio ?] recording
from the one demonstrating
there that there are disparity
selective neurons that
are tuned that then provide
the hardware, if you will,
for being able to analyze
stereoscopic depth.
So that then summarizes
what I wanted
to tell you about
motion parallax.
And now we are going
to go on and talk
about yet another
important depth
cue that is utilized by the
brain, which is called shading.
Now remember that our ability to
use light to illuminate things
is something that was
practically nonexistent
for endless millions of years.
And so because of that,
both animals and us,
we have to heavily
rely on information
based on light coming from
the sun, coming from above.
And shading is based on those
millions of years of evolution
utilizing the fact that
most of the light that
illuminates things
comes from above.
So there are all kinds
of nice examples of this.
And here is one of them.
What you can do here is you
can take a bunch of disks
and set them up so.
You can do this on a computer
to make the upper part
light and the lower part
dark or the other way
around, the upper part
dark and lower part light.
And all of you readily
can see that these images,
the first and third row, seem
to be protruding towards you.
And the images in the second and
fourth row seem to be receding.
Now that is because the
brain is interpreting
that on the basis of the fact
that the light at least used
to come predominantly
from above.
So that is the basic
arrangement for seeing depth.
And now I'm going to give
you some demonstrations
to indicate that this cue
is actually quite powerful,
even when you would not
necessarily expect it to be.
So these shading cues have
also been extensively used
in art work to provide
an impression of depth.
And I will show
you some examples
that will give you a
sense of how that is done.
So let me make one more point
before I proceed that namely it
is, indeed, the
degree of illumination
that's crucial here.
We have the same change
from red to, sorry,
from some greenish to yellowish.
And you have no sense of
depth here whatsoever.
In other words, you do need
the shading information,
meaning the amount
of light that's
being reflected from
various surfaces, that
is crucial for perceiving depth.
So now what we
are going to do is
we are going to present a series
of slides that will highlight
the power that shading has
for the perception of depth.
So here is an example
of how we do this.
And the reason I'm
showing this in some
detail because if you really are
interested in stuff like this,
you can do all this
on your own computer.
You can play games,
endless games with it.
You can spend hours and
hours having a lot of fun
thinking about how depth
works on the basis of shading.
So what you have here are
a whole bunch of disks.
And each of these can
be shaded differently
by many different
computer programs.
So that's what you can do.
That's the basics.
So now what we can do
is we can play a game.
And we can say, present just
two different objects here.
But we're going to present them
repeatedly on a big display.
And then we can shade these
differently as we please.
So here is a whole
bunch of them.
And all the rows, this, the
first, third, and so on rows
are the same shape
and the second, fourth
and so on are the other
shape, these two shapes.
So we only have two shapes
here that are juxtapositioned.
Now what we can do is say, well,
this is a peculiar sensation.
I have a vague
sense that there's
something maybe in
the third dimension.
But it's not too well
defined, because this
is not in accordance with
the rules and laws of shading
of light coming from above.
So now what we can do
instead, we can selectively
shade these to be in accordance
with the rules of light coming
from above to create
shading and depth.
And when you do that,
here's an example of that.
What you can see here is
a very compelling image
of these protruding elements,
sort of protruding to the left,
right?
Everybody see, have a
strong sense of depth here?
So now what you can do
is you can play with it
and decide, well,
can we do something
that, keeping the
very, very same shapes,
shade them differently
and see what
it does to our
perception of depth.
And so what we are
going to do next
is we're going to take
each of these elements
here, the same ones
here, and we're
going to reverse the contrast.
You see the contrast
here on top is white
and the bottom is black.
So we're going to
reverse that contrast.
And when we do so, the question
is what are you going to see.
And if you do that,
low and behold,
you still have a
strong sense of depth.
But it's a very confusing sense.
You may see sometimes these
objects pointing to the left
and sometimes to the right.
It's unstable, because you're
confusing those computations
that have evolved
over millions of years
for interpreting depth
in terms of shading.
Now you can play also
some additional games.
You can make this even more
complicated, make more changes,
and here is another one.
You still have a
feeling of depth.
But it's totally confusing.
It's very hard.
You can't organize it
any way, because it
is not in accordance
with the law of light
coming from above
to a real object.
And lastly, you
can also make this
so that it would be in
accordance with the laws.
But you can change
it around so that you
get a completely
different perception,
a strong sense of depth.
It's still the very,
very same elements
that you had seen before.
But now the shading is
done, again, differently.
And then now gives you,
again, a unified sense
of a display that
is not conflicting.
Because in this case, it's
in accordance with that
some of the basic
principles of shading.
So now, what we can do next,
having talked about stereo
and we have talked
about shading,
is to look at some
more of the demos.
So let's go back
to the stereoscope.
And let's go back
to the handouts.
And so if you now come to the
next page that has a heading
called stereo and shading.
So, again, take the
stereoscope and we
are going to look
at these in steps.
So let's start by looking
at the top display
first, which is
called stereo only.
So if you look at
that, first of all,
if you just look at it
without the stereoscope,
you see pretty much a
sort of flat display
of a truncated pyramid.
Then if you put the stereoscope
there and look through it,
you should see, if you look
at it for a little while,
that one of those
sticks out towards you
and the other one
seems to recede.
Does everybody see that?
So let's stop there
for a minute, because I
want to add one more
fact here, which
I should have mentioned earlier.
So what you do here
is-- so you have
these two displays like that.
And you have one image here
and another image here.
When you-- this is
greatly exaggerated,
these coming together like this.
That means it's
going to stick out
towards you as you look at it.
But if you do the
opposite like that,
they're further apart
than the rest of them.
Then actually you
see it receding.
And that's why, if you now
take away the stereoscope
and look at it, you can see
that the top left image is
in each, or facing
towards each other,
whereas the other ones are
facing away from each other.
And that's what creates, that's
what the brain interprets,
as protruding versus receding
using the stereoscope.
So that is very
similar, in a way,
to what happens with shading.
So now if you look
at the second image
there, first without the
stereoscope, what you see here,
again, is one that
sticks out just
like in the original display.
And the rest of
them are receding.
That's because the shading,
the one that sticks out
is light on top and
dark on the bottom.
And it's the obverse
for the other ones.
Now if you do the
same thing looking
through the stereoscope,
what you will see
is still some degree of depth,
but it's not very pronounced.
Because there is no
corresponding disparity
information.
But now if you look
at the third display,
where stereo and shading are
in harmony, then what you see
is an extremely
compelling dramatic sense
of depth with the top
left one sticking out
towards you and the
other three receding.
So shading appeared to have
added to the compelling nature
of the depth that you see
through the stereoscope.
Now the last image in here is
that we put stereo and shading
and conflict with each other.
And when you do that, you can
look at it, first with just one
eye, then with the other eye.
When you look at it with both
of them, you, for a while,
you see something unstable.
And when you see it
well, eventually, you
realize that there
is a conflict there
because of the
shading and the stereo
being in opposition
to each other.
Now then, this kind of effect,
if you go to the next page,
we're going to go now to
page five, six, and seven.
Again, what you
need to do here is
to look at it sideways
with the F's on top.
And when you look at this, those
of you who can use your eyes so
that they are divergent,
and you look beyond it,
then this is very much like,
or it is the same actually,
as an auto stereogram.
So if you look at this for a
while, and you look beyond it,
eventually it's going to gel.
And when it gels,
what you should
see is where the
F's are, the images
are protruding towards you,
and the others are receding.
Now it may take you awhile.
It's much more difficult
than what we just
did with the stereoscope.
But you should be
able to see that.
How many of you are able to
actually see those images?
A little bit di-- move it back
and forth a little bit slowly.
And maybe eventually
you manage it.
So as I say, where
the F's are you
see these images-- these
truncated pyramids protruding
towards you.
And the rest of
them are receding.
If you have difficulty
seeing this,
I'm not surprised, because
it takes a lot of practice.
But once you get
a sense of it, I
think that you will enjoy
doing this and actually
showing it to some
of your friends.
So then if you go
to the next page,
there we have added shading.
And the shearing is
the same everywhere.
But the stereo cues are not.
Once again, what
happens is that they
are stereo cues where
the F's are stick out
towards you much
greater than the others.
They stick out a lot less
because of the added stereo.
And then, in the last demo
there, the last page, we
are putting, just like in that
figure with a stereoscope,
we are putting them into
opposition with each other.
And so when you
look at these, this
would be very difficult
to see for a while.
Because there's a tendency
to see it differently
for stereo and for
motion parallax.
And so it's going to
be an unstable percept.
So what you can do then
is you can play around
with this at your leisure and
especially once you become more
proficient looking at
all the stereograms,
if you go and get one of these
magic eye books to look at,
you will be able to see
these displays as well.
So now, this is the one was the
first one that I showed you.
As I said, this one, with
the F's, are the ones
that should stick
out closest to you.
Once you see that, then
you can go on to the next
to add the shading or
subtract the shading from it.
So now, an interesting
question that arises
is to what degree are we
able, or are animals able,
to integrate these different
kinds of depth cues.
And in particular,
in this case, you're
going to ask the question, what
about integrating stereopsis,
parallax, and shading.
So the experiment is
one done on monkeys
in which you can present
these cues either singly
or in combination.
And we can ask the
question, well,
does the monkey do better
with one or the other,
or does he integrate really
and does really much better
when you provide all three cues.
And so here is a procedure.
What you do here, again,
you have a rocking display
like this, and you
can present this
either with shading
as shown here
or with motion parallax where
it rocks back and forth,
and lastly also with stereopsis.
So if you do that, the results
you get are quite dramatic.
What happens is shown here as
a percent correct performance
and here is the latency
in milliseconds.
And it shows that the monkey
does extremely well when
you present-- this
is percent correct.
This is degrees of disparity.
The monkey does extremely well
when you present all three cues
and does worse when you present
each of those cues alone.
Even more dramatic
is the fact, and this
is-- I keep coming back to
this, that the ability for us
to respond quickly to things
is very important for survival.
And here what we can see is
that when you present all three
cues, performance is much,
much, much, much faster than
when you present
each of those alone.
And, of course, as
you might expect,
when you present parallax
only, because that's
motion over time, that
takes the longest to do.
So even though motion
parallax cues are great,
it became important in
the course of evolution
to create mechanisms that
can detect these things more
quickly and more efficiently.
So now we come to
yet another cue
that we know very little about
at the level of the brain
or single units, because
it's so complicated, which
is called perspective.
But I want you to just be aware
of it and have a sense of it.
And here is one of
those cartoon examples
that gives you a very
strong sense of depth.
And you almost cringe.
If you were there,
you would worry
that you would be falling down.
This is done strictly by
virtue of perspective.
It's very similar to what you
encounter all the time when
you're driving down a road and
the road seems to converge,
even though you're
not aware of it.
But that's what's happening
on the rental surface.
Because things further away
are smaller than things
that are close by.
And that's when you look
down a railroad track,
the same thing happens,
even though you
know that the railroad
track is not converging,
it's going parallel.
But because of the
distances involved,
that's what falls on the retina.
And you're smart enough to
know that even though that's
what falls on the
retina, you can
make the right kind
of interpretation.
Conversely, you can
also compute the depth
on the basis of that
kind of convergence.
Now here's another example
of that, a much simpler way
that people can do
with experiments.
Here we have a bunch of dots.
And we have two basic cues that
have to do with perspective.
One of them is this gradually
decreasing size of these dots.
I should say elongated
disks, if you will,
and also that they
are converging
much like a railroad
track converges.
And so we have a
very strong sense
of having a third
dimension here.
Now the fact that
this is so strong
can be mitigated by
adding a few things here.
If you add some more dots,
it's not question as dramatic.
And then if you start
mixing up the sizes,
you are beginning to lose it.
And then if you
totally mix it up,
then you have no sense
of that left at all.
So it is that progression
of steps and sizes
and whatnot that
gives you the sense
of the depth of the images
that you're looking at.
Now here's another
converse example
of this that is an illusory
effect that what you see here
is three barrels, if you will.
And this barrel is a lot
bigger than this barrel, right,
or is it?
Well, so what we're
going to do here,
we have an inducing element here
by this hallway, if you will,
with a door at the end.
And we're going to
remove this hallway
keeping the barrels
exactly as they are.
And if you do that,
low and behold,
those barrels are
all the same size.
It's induced by virtue
of the surround that
gives you a false
sense of depth.
So now let me show you
another picture because
of the purpose behind this.
This a picture
that's in a museum
in Worcester, Massachusetts.
And it was created by a
fellow called Edward Savage.
And it's a pretty
unpleasant picture.
But the main reason
I'm showing this to you
is that there seems to be
very poor sense of depth
in this picture.
Now the reason
this is interesting
is because when artists
began, centuries
ago in the 13th, 12th
centuries, draw things,
they did not have a concept
of an understanding of how
to create depth, a third
dimension, in their drawings.
So what they did
eventually, they came up
with a so-called
vanishing point,
and they drew very much
like what we had here.
Lines that converged
at a point and then
scaled the images
accordingly rather
than keeping it the same size.
And that way you got
a good sense of depth.
So now that has a number
of interesting stories
about it that we
are going to discuss
next time you talk about
the perception of shapes,
OK, patterns.
But I will leave that
discussion until that.
What I'm going to do
next, however, I'm
going to try to give you a sense
of how important stereopsis can
be for the perception
of fine depths.
And so to do that, what I'm
going--I'm going to show you
actually a film.
And here what we have is
a so-called needle test.
What you have here is a
fine needle protruding.
And here we have a
bunch of different size
circular openings, a little bit
like a needle, but it's round.
And the task is to take these
one at a time and hang them up.
And one can time how
quickly you can do that,
or you can make a film to
see how well you can do it.
And then what we
can do is we can
test the subject under
binocular conditions,
and test them under
monocular conditions.
So I'm going to show you a film
of this, actually two films.
It will just take just
few seconds to do it.
OK, be ready, it's going
to come up in a second.
OK, here's the subject under
binocular viewing conditions.
So that's the condition
under binocular viewing.
And now I'm going to show it to
you, same subject, same time,
but with one eye closed off.
So that then just
even looking at it
without taking any
careful measurements.
It's obvious that
it's much, much
more difficult to thread
a needle under monocular
than under binocular
viewing conditions.
And so what you can do
is when you go home,
and next time you want
to sew something up,
try threading the needle with
one eye closed and with the two
eyes open.
And you will see immediately
what a huge difference it is.
And that difference,
therefore, is due
to you're having the
mechanism of steropsis.
Just a few seconds here.
Another test that has been
used in a similar fashion which
allows you to actually calculate
exactly what your error is
in reaching, you
can have a subject
sit in front of one
of these touch panels,
and then do this experiment
either binocularly or
monocularly.
And after he presses
this a dot comes up,
and then the person
has to touch it.
And you have about 30
or 40 trials like that.
And then you have recorded
where the person touched.
And, therefore, you
can calculate the error
between where we touched
and where the dot is.
And then, again, you
get a huge effect
between monocular and
binocular viewing conditions.
Now when you come to
monocular and binocular
viewing conditions, another
thing important to test
is to what degree a person
who does or does not
have stereopsis is capable
of integrating information
between the two eyes.
So to do that, we
have here examples
of what is called
binocular integration.
So what we do here, again,
you can use a stereoscope.
You look at a monitor.
And this represent the left
eye, this is the right eye.
And you flash these on.
If you integrate this,
this is what you see.
This would be actually
what you would
show in the control
part of the experiment.
So you see the Star of David.
And if a subject is
shown this, and they
don't see the Star
of David, you worry
that their ability to integrate
the information between the two
eyes is deficient.
And I would say 90% of the
cases, those people who
are deficient on this
also show major deficiency
in stereoscopic viewing.
Now another way to do
this is an experiment
in which you can present
two words here, sud and try,
so the two are separate.
And when you present
them simultaneously,
you actually see
the word sturdy.
So you ask the subject, please
tell us what do you see.
What is it word you see.
And the subject says sud.
And the subject
says try, then you
know that that subject
sees, if he says try,
he sees mostly with his
right and prefers it,
doesn't see too well
with his left eye.
If he says sturdy, then
he integrates the two.
And, therefore,
you can safely say
that this guy has very good
integration between the two
eyes.
So what I would
like to do next then
is to provide you with any
questions that you have.
This was a complicated
topic, that you have,
and then we are
going to summarize.
Does anybody have a question
about motion parallax,
stereopsis, and so on?
Let me maybe add one
more important factor.
Your eyes are separated
only by so many centimeters.
Now, can you think
of an animal where
there's a much
larger separation?
AUDIENCE: Hammerheads.
PROFESSOR: The hammerhead shark.
Yeah, that has a separation
of over a foot between the two
eyes.
And so you could ask the
question, why on earth did
that animal evolve to such a
huge separation between the two
eyes?
Well, that brings one to yet
another interesting point.
This I think may have started
during the Second World War.
It was realized that
when you're flying
over some territory, where
there are all kinds of weapons
and whatnot, which
are well camouflaged,
that just looking down at
them, you can't see them.
But obviously if you're
going to have a tank
or you're going to have a
gun or other that may be more
like a cannon, it sticks
out of the ground.
So it was discovered that
if you had in your airplane
two lenses which
are far apart, that
would greatly magnify the depth.
You could defeat
that camouflage.
And you could find
those weapons down there
by virtue of the fact they're
sticking out of the ground.
So the fact then is that the
more you separate the images
from the two eyes, if you
will, or your two cameras,
the more likely it is
that you can calculate
the disparity of information
between the two images.
So that then is probably
one of the reasons, not
the sole reason, but
maybe one of the reasons
why, in some animals, is
an excessive separation
between the two eyes.
And that brings me to get me
to yet another point, which
is that stereopsis actually
works best at relatively
short distances, like
threading a needle.
It doesn't work too well beyond,
I don't know, 10 feet or so.
It becomes progressively
less effective.
But at short distance,
it's very effective.
And so I presume
also many animals
that have to hunt for
food are able to utilize
the mechanism of stereopsis,
because everything
is at a close distance when they
hunt for food on the ground.
And by contrast, when you
talk about motion parallax,
that works extremely well
over very long distances.
So does anybody have any
questions about motion parallax
or about steropsis?
Oh, once again, I'm
crystal clear, huh?
So, therefore, I
think it's time for us
to summarize what we
had covered today.
First of all, there
are numerous mechanisms
that have emerged
for analyzing depth.
And they include the ocular
motor cues, which are vergence
an accommodation and then the
binocular cue of stereopsis
and then the monocular
cues of parallax shading
and perspective.
Then you have several
cortical structures
that process stereopsis.
You don't have one
specific brain area
that uniquely does this.
The number of disparities that
are represented in the brain,
as studies in the area of
the one by John [? Porgio, ?]
is limited.
And maybe, maybe four,
but there may be six,
but certainly there are
not a large number of them.
And so it's analogous
to the way things
had been resolved for us to
be able to process color.
Utilizing motion parallax
for depth processing
necessitates neuron specific
for direction, velocity,
and differential velocity.
Several areas getting V1 and
MT process motion parallax,
which I did not say.
But indeed, if you make
a lesion in area MT,
you go get a deficit in
motion parallax, even
thought you don't get a
major deficit in steropsis.
Now, area MT
combines the analysis
of motion parallax,
depth, and flicker.
However, these analyses
are also carried out
by several other structures
as I've already said.
And lastly, little
is know at present
about the manner in which
information about shading
and prospective are
analyzed in the brain.
And hopefully, that will
be one of the future tasks
by neuroscientists.
And so if any of you ever
get involved in neuroscience,
this certainly is
a big open area
that we hope people
will start to analyze.
So that then is the essence of
what I wanted to cover today.
And once again, if any of
you has a question, please,
please don't hesitate to ask.
I'll be very happy
to answer them.
OK, lastly then, did everybody
sign the attendance sheet?
If not, please come up after the
class and sign your name to it.
Very good.
So next time then,
we are going to talk
about pattern perception.
And hopefully you will
find that also interesting.